priya
our next speaker is ryan schicky from
institute
who's going to talk about large-scale
viral discovery
thanks tom can you hear me where
is it okay if i take my mask off anybody
has an objection
i would prefer thank you
so thanks a lot for the invitation this
is really an impressive lineup of
speakers during this workshop so i look
forward for interactions
uh i hope that this presentation are
actually happy but i believe that it's
on topic
for this
gathering because it's about large-scale
omics and i will talk about large-scale
genomics
although on a different topic so
non-human
mainly environmental
it's the same talk as cgsi for those of
you who attended the workshop in los
angeles
but
i hope you will still find interesting
and feel free to interrupt me and ask
questions during the talk if you would
like
so the title is with some progress
towards petabyte scale genomics
um i want just one slide from my
background and
i read bioinformatics i go event lab at
a city pasteur in paris my research
focuses on chemo methods genome assembly
these organisms are my small
contribution to the earth biogenome
project where i assembled those
organisms that was before actually high
quality genome assemblies so i don't
think they are being used nowadays
but still
and today i will talk about a project
which performed beta-based scale viral
discovery
as part of a bigger team called cerrados
and we analyzed all available rna
sequencing data publicly and we
discovered 10 times more viral species
than previously known including another
novel species of coronaviruses
so the context of this work is
relatively timely it's in the viral
surveillance in the aid of pandemics
so currently we are unfortunately at the
stage of global spread and it would be
nice if we could discover and contain
viruses before they spill over to humans
or to other animals
in particular for starscop2 it has been
known that it's circulated among animals
and it currently still circulates so
there are some excerpts from news
articles where sask of 2 has spilled two
tigers dogs and and links
and in particular for recent variants
which have been
hypothesized to come from rodents
so to
potentially
investigate and prevent future
spillovers dna sequencing that has
played a role
so there's essentially two types of two
sequencing one which is targeted
that has been the efforts of next train
giza and and so on
and then on the other side of the
spectrum you have environmental
sequencing which
doesn't target any particular virus but
for instance the taha ocean project
set out to sequence
all the microbial matter in oceans
across the across the globe
and in my talk particularly i will focus
on these types of sequencing data
so you're probably aware of the sra
which is the biggest database of
public sequencing data hosted at in
ncbi and ebi
jointly
so for those of you who are not this is
a database where you can search by
metadata and and essentially download
raw sequencing data for
pretty much all studies
where
the publishing of sequencing data is
maintained by a journal
a particular aspect of this database is
its explosive growth
so right now it's at 30 databases which
is 30 million of gigabases and it's
roughly doubling every two years
so in 2022 and in two years it would be
estimated to be at 60 better days of
public sequencing data
so when i think about the sra
i mainly think about the data crypt
where the reads are just sitting there
undisturbed unable to be fully analyzed
at a large scale
the main reason is because of its volume
all rna6 as of 2020 consisted of 5
million samples roughly 10 databases
if we were to analyze all of this data
we would need first download it and even
downloading is a challenge
as a small exercise for for the public
how many years will it take to download
10 better bases of data if you had a
bandwidth of 1 megabytes per second
yes
[Music]
lesson here
700. you can actually ask google for the
answer if you if you craft a query
worded like this it would immediately
spit out the correct answer which is
roughly 300 years just as of download
and you can realize that if even if you
had a lot faster access
to this database let's say 100 megabytes
per second it would still take you three
years for download so this is highly
unpractical to do for
pretty much any lab except ncbi and api
however we took advantage of a very
recent initiative by
ncbi to mirror all of this data
to cloud providers such as amazon and
google
and we were able to perform a cloud
analysis of all rna6
this is a product called serratus and we
have a website where you can actually
explore our results and i will briefly
talked about talking about our results
within this project
so in serratus we did two analysis one
is a nucleotide alignment of all rna
secretes
against
all known irreverent genomes
and with this analysis we discovered a
new species of coronary viruses
we then performed another analysis with
a protein translated alignment
of all iranian secrets
versus the marker gene of iranian
viruses
and through these analysis we discovered
130 thousand new renewable species
we did this second analysis after
realizing that nuclear type alignment
wasn't sensitive enough
for discovery of noble viral species
because we are really looking at at the
low homology alignment
so which couldn't be captured by by
nucleotide alignment unfortunately
so in analysis one we took
the rsi all sra rna6
downloaded and aligned using a classical
rhythm arena vote i2
against a pen genome of all rna
viral species
sequences from refseq
and through this analysis we discovered
that roughly 55 libraries were positive
for containing some sort of coronavirus
genome
so to perform this analysis we
developed a particularly tailored
architecture
that performs download very efficiently
on a cloud
using many many machines thousands of
machines at the same time
and alignment using also
5000 machines
and finally gathering of results in in
the form of bam files containing reads
matching
some some known virus
and finally we put all the data in in a
public repository which is an amazon s3
container and the whole pipeline in a
nutshell was aggressively cost optimized
to avoid
any possible overhead due to
um
for instance fast q passing downloading
and in order to be aggre to be
embarrassingly parallel
so we were able to use up to 20 000 vcps
at the same time and the whole pipeline
is open source
in terms of performance
this pipeline is able to align up to a
million libraries in a day
and in terms of cost the cost is roughly
half a penny per library
and this is
extremely optimized so you would
consider that the order
the question i often get is how much
does it cost to analyze all of sra
and it's in the order of a few tens of
thousands of dollars of dollars
which is significant but not stable
nowadays
so this enabled us to analyze i don't
know if it renders very well this is a
world map
this enables us to analyze
all of rna sequencing data and it has
been geolocalized because in the sra you
can get
geolocalization of each library so you
can see it's all over the world
there are some some real artifacts with
with straight lines which i believe are
not biologically correct
locations
in another analysis we also analyze all
of rna6 but this time it was a more
sensitive alignment using diamond 2
which aligned nucleotides towards
protein reference
and this time we aligned with two
non-versions of a particular gene of any
viruses
which enabled us to recover sub-files
containing reads
containing portions of this gene
potentially highly diverged
so the novelty of this work
is that we created a database of
the 15 000 known rna viral rdrp genes
which is a gene that you find in all rna
viruses
so you find it in polio coronaviruses
and other families it's structurally
very concerned
and in terms of sequence it has been
known that there are three domains a b
and c
which are highly conserved across all
rna viruses
so collaborators artem babin and robert
edgar wrote the software to actually
extract
from
any given sequence the motifs a b and
c's
for four
rdrps and this is software called um
spam scan and
this modif is called bam print it's
roughly a hundred amino acids long
and then using this pimp print we could
define
a threshold for species by clustering at
90 amino acid identity
so then in this analysis we recovered
all reads mapping to
viral drps and we perform we perform
micro assemblies so we just assemble
those reads which are matching rdrp
within each sample using a classical
assembler and
and some uh not so advanced logistics
so this enabled us to perform a really
large scale analysis of
of the sra on the left you can see a
distribution of the volume of data per
the type so there is human data of
course mouse
we took mammal wgs as a controller where
we didn't expect to find anything
because it's not rna-seq
and on the right here this is the
proportion of species of viruses which
are already known in grey and discovered
through these analysis in blue so
unsurprisingly we found many new viruses
in metagenomes biomes and environmental
samples but also a few new viruses in
human and other mammals
so this is the geographical distribution
of
of the um
containing samples that we found
and i won't go too much into details but
for we perform many analysis of these
different viral families where we expect
to find new viruses
so in this sort of graph
we get on a y-axis a number of sre
libraries and on x-axis a percentage
identity to non-rdrps
anytime you are in the region between 90
and 50 this corresponds to libraries
containing potentially new variances
new variable species which are
completely unknown
and so this differs by family so there
are some families which are much well
less studied than others
so for instance
most of the libraries contain known
species but a few still contain unknown
potentially unknown species
and coronavirus wasn't displayed in this
in this graph but it looks a little bit
like filo
it's in fact the family for which
we have characterized the viruses the
best
but still we found some libraries where
potentially new coronaval species exist
and in fact this is what i'm going to
talk next
so you can access all of our data by
typing database scale on google which
actually
it's funny if you type these terms all
of the first page hits corresponds to
our work
i'll briefly mention that we discovered
new coronaval species
in unexpected environments so
you you know potentially the the usual
tree of of corona viruses so alpha beta
data
gamma and we discovered new viruses that
we tentatively call group e
which correspond to viruses found in
aquatic species such as axolotl
foggo fish seahorse
and previously there was one one one
member of this group
which was found in a pacific salmon
it was the only known
night of virus and it wasn't clear that
it was a chronovirus but we
significantly significantly expanded
this family
one particular
aspect of these new coronal vowel
species is
that when we performed assembly we
couldn't recover the spike gene in any
of them
which is particularly surprising because
normally corner viruses always have a
spike change
but we looked a bit more in our data and
it turns out that the spike gene was in
fact present in the assembly but on
another context
the striking fact is that normally
coronary viruses exist in a single
molecule
so
we are unable to close the gap between
the
non-spike containing part of the virus
and the spike containing part if we look
at the pacific salmon
assembly that was previously known
it's in a single sequence however there
are a string of ends at exactly the
location where we had gaps in
other assemblies indicating that
the group which analyzed this virus had
performed some manual scaffolding
but currently our hypothesis is that
these viruses are segmented
and this would rewrite the definition of
what the coronavirus is because so far
none of the coherent viruses were
segmented
and this has important implications in
their evolution because we know that
segmented viruses such as influenza
can evolve faster due to exchanges for
instance of their other segments
more than recombinations
so to perform this work in terms of
methods we perform meta genome and
metadata home assembly so usually
metagenome assembly consists of
reconstructing all the genomes within a
sample which is a computationally
intensive task
in our first analysis we are focused on
reconstructing only the corona of our
species
this was computationally intensive
because to do this we had to perform
meta genome assembly
of the whole of the whole data and then
just filter out
of another species in analysis too we
only focused on rdrp genes and it was
much easier to
to perform because we only selected
reads matching our drp
for this project we actually had the
help from the spades assembly team which
wrote a particularly designed assembler
just for this project called time corona
speeds
which optimizes the construction of any
viruses through
better scaffolding
just to give some
overview of what it looks like behind
the scenes so we use aws batch which is
a framework for cloud scale analysis
which essentially allows you to submit
jobs to the cloud and it takes care of
all the
logistics such as running instances
scheduling jobs error tolerance and so
on so it looks a bit like this when i
was using it so you can have a dashboard
with number of running jobs the one who
succeeded please don't look too much at
the one which failed
and you can actually see all the
machines which are running and we can
also estimate the cost
in time
for our second analysis where we perform
assembly of all our drps we just did it
on a single machine a pretty big one but
it was enough to perform this in in
reasonable time
so at this point um now we know 10 to
the power of five vowel species but we
also know that there are 10 to the power
of left eight
left to discover so
much more work
ahead of us for any viruses we haven't
even looked at dna viruses
but it would be interesting future work
another one would be to look at even
lower homology detection of rdrps
because we are now limited by the
sensitivity of botox and diamond
but we know that these tools are limited
there are some opportunities to do even
lower homology alignment and in fact
some group in paris has investigated
this using deep learning
and finally one topic that is close to
my heart is to create a global index of
the sra
using for instance cameras
it's nearly feasible today but for sure
it would only support exact matches
however if we had this index we wouldn't
have needed to align all the reads
to
from the si and download all of them we
could just have used this index
however this index doesn't exist
yet
and it's a challenging contract
okay so as a summary so we performed
a discovery of 10 times more antiviruses
than previously known including one new
coronavirus genome i didn't talk about
it but in the paper we also look at
certain families which are quite
intriguing such as highly compressed
viruses which are only consisting of
more like
closer to 300 500 nucleotides
we called zeta viruses we also looked at
novel data viruses and novel huge
favorites
pages all our data is accessible on on
github and s3 that's a lot of alignment
and assemblies which have been left
analyzed unanalyzed so up for grabs for
any other group
more details are of course in the paper
many technical details are on github and
you can chat with us on slack
where
interested people can design projects
with us
it was not an usual project
in fact
this project stemmed from a online
hackathon
that was held in 2020
and essentially we welcomed
everyone it was initiated by artem
babayan and all the list of people you
see here are
people who heard of this hackathon and
decided to join the initiative
we didn't exclude anyone and pretty much
every participation was voluntary
so at the end we
ended up being all first offer of the
paper
so with all equal contribution
in fact we never met in real life
it was fully fully digital collaboration
so i'll conclude with this slide that i
took from artem but which
contains a message that i like
so
until this work the known rna viral was
symbolized by this red dot and with
serratus we significantly expanded it by
by 10x
however we must stay humble
because the earth firearm is even bigger
and there's much more to discover
so as a summary there's lots of genomics
data and many great analysis could be
made if we were able to do them
and my belief is that the cloud type
analysis help at the larger scale
so these are
some credits
of people who initiate these types of
analysis
and i'll briefly conclude by mentioning
my group attention tester but
that's
pretty much the themes of our work is to
do these types of analysis particularly
and also others
and i thank you for your attention
thanks so much that was exciting
questions
thank you very much
very nice so probably a very basic
question so how i mean sra is uh full of
sequences uh with low quality so how you
control for the quality of the data that
you are using and by extension your
false discovery rate
right so we estimated this in in a paper
by
confirming that any new vowel species
that we found was not only found in a
single library but in multiple ones
and
um so i i also somewhat disagree with
the fact that
sequencing data is low quality in
general so of course you can have many
artifacts such as contamination
um
camera camera creeds
however we should have some trust in
in sequencing data as it is provided to
us
really interesting talk also um a
question about the biology of the the
proposed segmented coronavirus
so i'm i'm sure you know that like the
discontinuous transcription
what is your hypothesis for how
basically you would get the
discontinuous transcription from the
rdrp and the segmented case it would
seem to be like a totally
biologically different function for the
rdrp
well so i'm not a biologist but my the
way i see this problem is that
the
the virus is present as a single
molecule
in the host or as multi as two molecules
and in the samples we really looked
closely at the assembly graphs and we
were unable to find any
genomic path between those two molecules
so there is no
sequencing based evidence
that
these two transcripts are
ever linked by by some sequence which
somehow we didn't find
i would love to follow up because the
way that transcriptional regulation
happens in coronavirus is through the
leader sequence being discontinuously
transcribed and essentially in a
functions almost like rna splicing but
not exactly and so this would imply if
there were actually a segmented virus
then it would imply there's transplacing
which would be very unusual so
interesting i'm happy to chat offline
about this although this is not
specifically myself
now i also find your talk really great i
had two different
questions so you didn't talk about the
length of the viruses um you found
any giant viruses also or is is your
approach
only able to discover viruses of a
certain length and maybe i overlooked
something in your slide no this is this
is a good question and in fact i want to
be clear that for
the analysis where we discovered 10
times more viral species we didn't
reconstruct the genomes of these viruses
we only reconstructed the
portion of the rdrp gene
so we have no idea okay of the length of
both viruses until we actually
go to those libraries and reconstruct
them one by one which would be a
monumental effort which would require us
to perform metagenome assembly
at a large scale
okay i didn't get that i don't know
my second question was we and others
have found a lot of
viral contamination of media
um so many different
media are
uh
infiltrated by
by
viruses that shouldn't be there so so
when you say that you have a sample from
a given place in the world
have you looked at some of these
contamination papers and and and
so we did find some unusual host for all
associations this is your question so i
remember one example on top of my head
is the plant which contained a human
virus
or a mammal mammalian virus so this
wasn't expected and the current
hypothesis was that
the plan
actually received um
some poop from an another viral and it
was all sequenced together that doesn't
mean that the plant has been infected
by this virus
all
preparation of sequencing um
potentially yes we didn't investigate
these kids is so so crazy
that must happen
did you see the new rna viruses that
infect bacteria
paper a couple weeks ago
did another big birom assembly you know
came out after years but was arguing
that for folks who don't know usually
rna viruses only infect eukaryotes
um and so there's some evidence from
these big large-scale cities of uh short
read assembly but there may be rna
viruses that infect bacteria that sounds
very interesting you didn't look in your
data have a look i wonder if you see
them also okay one more here
so this is
uh was mostly ironic right the only only
are music and these are mostly called
samples right
i mean it's pretty much all of people
yeah but human problem so you can look
at whether there is any correlation with
the tissue already whether there were
some viruses or
that were found in particular tissues or
you didn't look at the research so you
didn't look whether
that was a hint of past infection in
which you could do some geographical
plastic of uh bible recovery a
particular time of location
or there is no
maybe not an operator look into this but
maybe that is you
just asking i know so um
so passing as a husky metadata is a bit
of a challenge so
that would be an interesting question
that probably requires some dedicated
efforts to investigate
i actually suggest that the metadata is
extremely important as well so if you
build an index of the sla
i think having the metadata
[Music]
curation metadata
[Music]
let's thank both of the speakers
[Applause]
we're now having a coffee break uh we'll
be back here at three o'clock